Jimmy and Michael here at CES 2017 the
show you know has a bunch of surprises
and crazy things this might be the
craziest thing that you know we've seen
so far where razors booth checking out a
project Valerie which is a gaming laptop
with three 4k monitors Michael what do
you think about it it's it's a lot more
compact than I initially thought just
from the preview stuff that we saw it is
a 17-inch monitor yeah there are 3 17
inch monitors all displaying in 4k which
is which is surprising to because of the
power that's packed into the pc itself I
believe it's a desktop 1080 powering all
these monitors and I'm surprised by how
well it also runs games we tested out
battlefield one i believe it was running
4k on all screens at Ultra settings they
said yeah quasi electricity yeah the
frame rates were like a book 30 i would
say i was bouncing between about 30 and
40 the action wasn't too crazy though at
the at those points so i would like to
see it in an actual multiplayer match we
have multiple things happening I think
it's worth mentioning that this is just
a prototype as a matter of fact razor
isn't sure if they're going to release
it or not one thing we had a chance to
use it in the back and one thing that
you know stood out to me was that to say
that it is warm as generous it was
scolding hot you know like the W key the
WASD keys were really hot like so much
so that it could probably do some damage
to you if you use a long enough yeah
just my hands on the keyboard was pretty
warm itself but I believe that the blood
of the hardware is placed above the
keyboard and it was very hot there so I
mean it is a prototype but there are
concerned that I would be concerned with
how hot it will get especially when the
action gets ramped up in a game like
Battlefield one where it's going to be a
lot more demanding so i think it's a
it's a cool concept but we'll see what
they what they do with it with new
iteration yeah I mean they mentioned
that like they're not right now it's
outfitted with a 1080 they say they're
not gonna outfit it with attending it's
probably something more power-efficient
something a little bit more powerful and
they also said that it's not coming out
this year we know that much but you know
final question you know is this
something that you would you
this is something that you you know
you'd want to buy ya a lot of the things
we're seeing at CES I think I'm always
asking myself what's the use case
scenario and a lot of lot of the higher
end stuff it's tailored for a specific
market so for myself I don't know if I
would personally use it but I mean if
also no price yet either yeah there's no
price set to it and I mean it could also
be used for extra productivity when you
need triple monitors but I think that as
games get more demanding and the
hardware ramps up as well with new
prototypes of this thing all right I'm a
little skeptical as to how it's going to
keep up with new games especially at
Ultra settings and displaying 4k so but
we'll see what they do with it for more
tech coverage and everything CES stay
tuned to gamespot com